the Joe Rogan experience that house I
lived in Boulder nine [ __ ] years ago
and that house is still for sale oh yeah
can't sell it it's a nice house they
can't tell that how I changed the name
of the street I Trent Reznor Marilyn
Manson don't wanna buy it do you like
rock stars were like really weird like
eccentric people that want to like have
something like that no nobody wants a
buy a house where a kid was killed good
enough deal how how expensive is it it's
a good deal not a great deal I know you
imagine a crazy [ __ ] like you're on
Steve in the middle to show you see like
things behind you ghosts you know the
thing about the Comedy Store podcasts
down that basement like dumb bait that
paid millions of people when killed in
that base of it [ __ ] for you that was
like Bugsy Siegel's place that was syros
nightclub so like for sure if you're
gonna kill somebody you kill him in the
basement right yeah how many guys do you
think they killed in that basement Bugsy
see you all with a nightclub on Sunset
for sure a gang of people think it's
probably a bunch of people killed as it
since it's been the Comedy Store well
there's probably while we know there's
one that once merger took place in the
base patio oh the front pass yeah yeah
that was close on my way there that
night tells crazy
yeah great alibi jar near streets are
many miles away
Louis J Gomez get it right for the press
release yeah yeah I whenever some reason
a documentary comes out about an old
thing that I've heard a thousand things
about I'll still watch him again I've
got way deep into Charles Manson again
but I was the same Chuck Manson was
people have bought those houses for sure
yeah it's the house is sold over and
over telling you right now it's true
they haven't marketed that [ __ ] house
the right way because they could get
some weirdo to buy it
he said Amityville Horror house those
[ __ ] nothing never really have
they're right it depends on your
documentary you want me to be like the
whole thing's fake
yeah you think probably all fake I think
it's kind of [ __ ] I think they just
sort of concocted it for that movie I
want to see that movie
I was scared out of my [ __ ] mind yeah
I was thinking oh my god these people
they bought this house and it's haunted
[ __ ] man that sucks what if that was us
but then you react then you found out
what based on true events means yeah cuz
like this I heard a weird creak in the
middle of the night and like bees came
out of your toilet the bees came out the
wall started bleeding I grew up so poor
that like just the idea of buying a
house I was watching those movies I was
like I don't know what do you want to
say guys I'm renting one Section eight I
would [ __ ] deal with the ghosts tell
me something yeah I know right were you
scared of a few ghosts would have ghost
ever done and never killed anybody
[ __ ] ghost killed them no one's ever
died from a ghost yeah it's always like
they moved a toy car like across a table
or something with that get past that
people I had my mom my roommate back
when I was like 21 my buddy jimmy
detillo
me and him got a Ouija board once we
said all right we're gonna find out this
is [ __ ] and he's like you're not
gonna move it right and I go I'm not
gonna move it I go you're not gonna move
he goes I'm not gonna move that [ __ ]
thing because we're gonna find out this
is [ __ ] and we sat around for like
an hour 45 minutes of this [ __ ]
stupid Ouija board ask any questions at
the end of it my friend jimmy folds
everything up stuffs it in the garbage
bag goes I'm taking this piece of [ __ ]
out to the trash right now I mean people
convince themselves of everything you
know let's start moving that thing like
oh my god it's going to the a I can't
believe in the end and the DS it's
telling you something Andy from beyond
the grave
fake martial arts where they're using a
[ __ ] knock you down do you think you
people that that prayer them are
predators do you think like the people
who go I'm talking to idiots - that's
the problem though they pieces of [ __ ]
they're both theirs
pieces of [ __ ] that some of them are
just con artists some of them are idiots
who are as fooled by it as what they're
teaching there's a la me that's Sylvia
Browne wasn't she the one that told the
girls they found in Cleveland like told
what her parents like she's moved on to
a better place now and right yeah like
stop looking for your daughter was dead
and she was in a [ __ ] at that's crazy
no she made them stop looking hurt is
that than religion though so I you know
I guess it they're the person that's
doing that on a dumb [ __ ] stage more
personal yeah no religion you are
basically you're you're projecting these
ancient stories right that's what you're
doing you're giving lessons and these
ancient stories but when you're actually
doing it to a single person that seems
way worse right yeah it's very focused
and also religion people get there are
good intentions sometimes the people
doing it doesn't follow tradition and
stuff or you grow up that way and you
just kind of like but I mean no that's
like that that's that's predatory did
someone make money might explain like
the worst possible thing about their
life in terms of is it truth they're
both equally probably you know like
[ __ ] but one is directly targeting
and [ __ ] with somebody and religions
also probably killed millions and
millions and millions of people and you
know these people are just [ __ ]
duping a few idiots out there
duping a lot of idiots but those idiots
deserve to be duped I mean look
wounded antelopes should not go to the
waterhole that's just how it goes
you get Jack everything is an antelope
analogy you Joe well this is the dumbest
always work they're supposed to get
taken out
[Applause]